qu'ils reviennent d'algérie nous
donneront une bonne nouvelle à ceux qui
aiment les livres zola ou de maupassant
pour dix bals bernard pivot est ravi
nous vous montrerons le tournage du
tournage du dernier lelouch
mais nous commencerons par l'hommage au
prodige en quelques semaines à peine
philippe candeloro est passé du bronze à
l'argent 3e à lillehammer deuxième au
championnat du monde au japon
le talent et le culot de quoi être
enthousiaste avec notre envoyé spécial
yann lavoix
on finit par connaître son programme
parker et pourtant on ne se lasse pas de
voir philippe jouer les tons candeloro
il a par cette petite faute il a exécuté
à merveille son programme libre
c'était encore du boca lillehammer
confirmation du coach andré brunet
confirmation des japonaises aussi en
équipage
comme nous elle j'aurais voulu le voir
en or mais lui se contente bien
volontiers de l'argent c'était que
j'arrive sur le podium aujourd'hui pour
confirmer les jeux olympiques
et en plus je les failles beaucoup de
punch et j'ai fait presqu'un un meilleur
programme court aux jeux olympiques donc
pour moi c'est génial quoi il a même
espéré pendant cinq minutes pouvoir
devenir le nouveau champion du monde
dans son vestiaire il a les yeux rivés
sur la télé sur le canadien josh qu
elvis stojko un véritable athlète qui
sait qu'il doit réussir combat de
candeloro un quadruple saut et c'est
réussi une combinaison exceptionnelle un
quadruple suivi d'un triple saut
réception un peu manqué mes succès à
sion
philippe est le premier à le féliciter
ils ont un style similaire et les deux
hommes s'aiment beaucoup quand elle n'a
donc pas de regrets
non pas du tout ce que je lis tyco a été
meilleur que moi ce soir avec un
quadruple boucle piqué triple boucle
piqué en combinaison de deux triples
axels le programme parfaitement exécuté
là on peut rien faire je veux dire il
est meilleur que moi ce soir je le
laisse gagner et son regret parce qu'il
a vraiment le papier comme un dieu mes
plats qui c'est un exemple pour nous
tous les jeunes et puis pour moi aussi
un mois après lillehammer ils ont tous
les deux graves il marche du podium pour
man up au champion olympique a terminé
quatrième et on admire à la personne